well get ready to laugh this labor day
weekend sarah silverman is making a stop
at the encore theater at the wind and i
got the chance to talk with sarah ahead
of the show it's called sarah silverman
and friends check it out
if this show i know is going to be so
much fun sarah silverman and friends
tell us a little bit about what we can
expect
uh it's you know it's sarah and friends
i've you know the truth is when you when
a comic does a and friends show it's
great because you see other great comics
but it's because i don't have an hour
yet like i i don't have new i have like
i don't know 30 40 fresh minutes but
like i can't fill out the whole show
so
i bring on brilliant you know three
brilliant other comics to fill it out
and and um
and that's how you develop an hour sarah
silverman and friends takes over the win
stage on labor day weekend i've got the
brilliant
uh rory albanese
who i'm also is my lover
and uh todd glass who also is my lover
and otsco okadska who is also my lover
no
so lots of lovers and lots of friends
you're good friends and lovers tour
that's what we should call it in
addition to expanding her stand up and
taking on new movie roles she can also
add podcast host to her already
impressive resume every week i'm like
just be funny you know
because i feel like i'm going into this
like serious place all the time but
people call in with real problems and
you know if i think i have something to
offer i can't help it you know i've
turned into my mother but for now she's
ready to bring all the laughs to vegas
just being there and the energy of the
audience just changes it it makes it
very vague
although i don't know if i'm gonna be
wearing anything sparkly
i'm gonna bring a little sparkle to the
stage and i do feel like you have to
wear something sparkly in vegas
you have to find something yeah well you
bring your own kind of sparkle so that's
all we need
you know i had to talk to sarah about
sparkles right
you can see sarah silverman and friends
this sunday september 4th at 8pm that's
at the encore theater at the wynn and
tickets are still available